so I think I've always been a pretty
stubborn person I guess I must have been
about 13 years old when my mom first
told me to stand up straight
but it was only last month so a decade
later that I finally decided it was
about time to do that
that motion there 10 years in the making
it's not that I have a problem with
authority figures per se it's just that
I really don't like being told what to
do unless I can fully understand the
reasons behind doing it I've always been
quite good as well as justifying to
myself why I shouldn't be taking other
people's advice like with standing up
straight I think I decided that
slouching was just a more accurate
representation of who I actually was
which is like a lazy shy old man in the
body of a teenager like I convinced
myself I was somehow doing a service to
the people around me by showing myself
in my true form what I've ended up
learning those that confident people
don't stand up straight to show the
world who they are the mere act of
standing up straight is actually enough
to make you feel more confident um it
does also hurt you back a little bit if
you're not used to it but that is the
price you pay to feel better about
yourself and it's not just posture Eva I
actually found myself getting quite a
major confidence boost recently all
because I bought a new pair of shoes for
context I have been wearing the same
type of shoe every single day since I
was a teenager basically ever since I
realized that I could put these shoes on
faster than any other shoe I'd worn
previously I entered into a very
committed and ultimately destructive
relationship with them like it didn't
matter to me that they always get holes
in the toes every single time I was
willing to look a bit scruffy if it
meant I could get out of the door 10
seconds earlier then I bought these and
you know what yes they do take me an
embarrassingly long amount of time to
put on but they do look more grown-up
and I've had at least five different
people compliment me on them since I
bought them like if 16 year old Charlie
knew that I was embracing fashion over
usability and it was making me feel good
I think he'd like bernoulli's clothes
and start wearing a bin liner or
something but you know what I'm not that
person anymore I like shoes now
apparently and that is what I would like
to invite you to have a think about
today shoes goodbye you
just had the almost imponderable so what
is one thing that you thought you would
never change about yourself and then you
did let me know however you like I feel
like it would be an interesting thing to
think about and if you can't think of
one write down on a piece of paper what
is one thing you know you will never
change about yourself and then put it in
a safe place look at it in ten years
time and find out how wrong you were
that's it for me goodbye for real you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool um Emily wants me to
reveal a little secret to you so it's
really hot today I have to have all of
the blinds closed and everything so I'm
wearing this shirt
so anybody down to there so behind the
scenes thank you very much for watching
as always here is my previous video in
case you missed it it's of me dancing
around like an idiot and completely
unrelated here is a portrait that Nathan
wyvern did of me painted using the
medium of tea obviously and the rest is
up to you good luck